Konnichiwa, arigato gozaimasu !
La dernière fois que je suis allé au Japon, j'avais.. j'avais acheté plein d'articles what the fuck dans un.. dans un magasin !
Et j'viens de les retrouver, j'avais couplètement oublié héhé..
Énorme le con ! Donc c'est parti on va tout tester ! Premier article :
Quel est ceci ? C'est une "duck face" qui apparemment te rend "kawaï"..
...
Nani ("quoi") ? Donc en faite ça se mord.. ça se mordille ?
Eh ça vient du Japon j'me méfie..
(magnifique danse des canards)
C'est nul.. Attend mais pt'être en photo duck face ça marche attend..
Mhpff ! Horrible ! N'achetez jamais cet article je sais plus combien.. heureusement
j'ai oublié les prix auxquels j'ai acheté tous ces trucs parce-que mec..
Si ce truc vaut clairement plus de 2 euros c'est de l'arnaque. Totale. ALORS SUIVANT !
Putain le moi de y'a 6 mois était vraiment beaucoup moins mature ! (rires)
Un sifflet en forme de couilles ! Ou comment faire perdre sa crédibilité
à ton prof d'EPS qui en a déjà pas beaucoup. Ah mais nan en fait c'est pas des couilles.
Mais nan en fait c'est des seins.. LE GAG PARFAIT POUR TA PROCHAINE GRANDE PARTY !
Nan mais c'est génial mec, en fait il font passer ce truc pour genre "L'OBJET" qui va faire que ta soirée
avec tes potes elle est trop cool, c'est génial. C'est juste un sifflet en forme de seins.
Les mecs ils ont tout dans l’exagération. (bruit de sifflet)
mais il siffle même pas il ne siffle même pas
j'ai envie de me flinguer.Aller on reprend la course plus vite que sa on fait un 3 x 500
OH OH
J'ai acheter une culotte.12 EUROS
Ah non je sais ce que sais franchement  tu combine ça et le siflet mec
t'es sur un stade de pervers assez ouf
en gros c'est masque anti pollution japonais (rire)
en forme de culotte
Oh ça pue ! Ça sent pas du tout la culotte japonaise
C'est pas parce que j'ai un masque en forme de culotte que je suis un pervers c'est une blague bon
* Siffle *
Alright !
Oh non pas ça oh non pas ça
mec ça c'est le vrai truc glauque ça s'appelle "tenga men's loupe"
et vous avez pas envie de savoir ce que c'est
Apparemment un fois que tu l'as essayé tu fais vraiment cette tête
C'est une loupe pour observer tes spermatozoïdes
Est-ce que c'est la fin de ma carrière ? Peut-être
Je ne vais bien évidemment pas éjaculer dans cet outil.
Par contre, on va mettre un autre truc qui va être rigolo à regarder, c'est un poil, la racine d'un cheveu ou d'un poil.
Vous allez voir, c'est très dégueulasse.
J'suis en train de galérer avec cet emballage ça va m'énerver
Hop là!
Attends mais mec, c'est hyper clean quoi regardez
C'est pas du tout... les mecs ils rigolent pas quoi
On dirait carrément un truc pour faire une prise de sang! C'est génial. Okay, la loupe est là
Ici tu as le... une poche *Montre la poche bizarrement*
On veut pas avoir à quoi elle sert. Et une pipette bien sûr
On veut non plus savoir à quoi elle sert. On a deux trucs comme ça, y'en a un qui se colle à l'objectif de ton téléphone
C'est avec ton téléphone que tu vas observer
ton sperme bien sûr, dans le métro de préférence bien évidemment.
Ok, je viens de placer le truc du coup qui fait zoomer. Techniquement tu mets ton.... ton...
ton p*tain de sperme, c'est dégueulassse
sur l'autocollant et tu colles l'autocollant à ça, voilà, comme ça ça crée une protection pour pas imbiber ton- ton téléphone de- Oh p*tain, j'en ai marre
Bon mec on va le faire avec un cheveu, vous en faites pas, d'façon ch'uis en train de les perdre
* Rires *
Tiens, attends, avec un poil.. Tu sais les longs poils noirs dégueulasses qui répugnent tout le monde
AH !
C'est bon, je l'ai !
Okay, le poil est mis, le poil est mis,
mes empreintes digitales avec.
Vous voyez ? Ça a juste un truc transparent avec un poil
j'suis vraiment en train de mettre ma main comme une youtubeuse beauté, c'est terrible.
Je n'ai plus qu'à le mettre là
Hop là, ça tient tout seul, attention
J'vais vous dire si c'est ouf
Appareil photo, c'est le moment de prendre un selfie
Oh !
C'est mon poil !
Ceci vient de mon corps,  c'est un-
on est en train d'observer mon poil mais genre de ouf ! Mec !
Ha ha ! On dirait une patte d'araignée !
Regarde !
Comme il est beau !
Mais en fait c'est trop bien !
J'ai critiqué avant de regarder, vous avez vu ?
J'ai fait mon vieux con, mon vieux haineux
C'est vraiment de la macroscopie ce qu'on est en train de faire, c'est trop cool !
Est-ce que ce terme existe ?
Peut-être pas, peut-être qu'en fait c'est un autre terme
* comme microscopie *
et que je suis juste pas cultivé du tout.
Mec, j'pourrais observer ce poil pendant des heures
J'ai l'impression d'être en cours de SVT au collège, je suis en train de kiffer ma vie !
P*tain c'est génial ! En plus c'est trop bien parce que tu peux partager ça sur les réseaux sociaux et tout !
Bah tes, tes spermatozoïdes ça peut intéresser plein de gens !
C'est trop bien !
Il faut que j'offre ça à Nozman, il va devenir fou
Allez, on arrête les bêtises, on jette tout ça
J'vais pt'être le garder ça quand même pour euh ... Nan, nan, c'est pas ce que vous croyez
Bref, revenons à nos articles un peu moins, un peu moins scientifique
C'était génial !
En vrai c'était génial !
Qu'est-ce que c'est qu'ça ?
Pourquoi j'ai acheté ça ?
Ça n'a aucun sens
Mais c'est quoi ?
Faut faire quoi en fait ?
C'est sûr j'ai acheté ça juste parce que c'est un Exotic Shorthair comme Jumbo
Bah mec, on va lui trouver une p'tite place hein
Ah bah non mais bon, voilà, nous on est comme ça, on adopte
Hop !
Et voilà !
Comment trouver une utilité à un objet en moins d'une seconde
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
C'est un truc pour s'arracher les poils de nez, ça va nous faire du bien, allez on y va
Attends, y'a 2 kits
* Rires *
On va faire un guet-apens à Micka !
Oh, c'est quoi ça ?
Un masque hydratant en forme de chat !
C'est génial !
Allez, vas-y
Mec, ça se trouve j'vais faire une allergie, mec j'vais avoir 600 000 boutons
Oh p*tain, mais mec ça-
Il a tourné ou quoi le truc ?
Ça pue la m*rde, c'est un truc de ouf
* mais qu'est-ce que je suis en train de regarder ? *
Je suis un chat
Miaou.
Oh p*tain !
C'est cool en plus y'a Jimmy, il ne sait pas ce qui l'attend
* Rires *
Jimmy : Alors attends, vraiment j'arrive, comme ça
Squeezie : T'aurai jamais due venir maintenant !
Okay, okay, maintenant cette vidéo va prendre une tournure exceptionelle
Squeezie : Les gars, j'vais me laver le visage parce que là j'en peux plus
Jimmy : Alors qu'est ce qu'on a ici ?
Que des trucs what the fuck, c'est ça ?
* Siffle *
Jimmy : Mais c'est dégueulasse !
Squeezie : C'est un sifflet paire de seins, t'as vu ?
Jimmy : Oui, j'ai vu, c'est excellent ça
Squeezie : Bah ça vient du Japon
Jimmy : C'est pas mal
Squeezie : Laisse-moi m'asseoir, va prendre une chaise !
Jimmy : Assieds-toi sur mes genoux
Squeezie : Okay, je m'assois sur tes genoux, tu veux me pécho...
Salut, c'est la bromance !
Squeezie : Alors Jimmy, tu vois cette image ?
Ça c'est nous dans moins d'une minute.
Squeezie : Je sais que t'es un peu-
Jimmy : J'suis très hésitant !
Squeezie : Toi t'es un peu garni du nez, hein ?
Squeezie : T'as un peu de euuuh ...
Jimmy : Ah j'ai des-
* Rires *
Squeezie : Ah, apparemment c'est un pack pour 18 personnes. Micka ?
Jimmy : Oh mais non, oh la la...
* Rires *
Squeezie : Au cas ou t'as la pif mon gars mais heu... énorme !
Squeezie : C'est compliqué mec regarde ça, c'est compliqué, y'a beaucoup d'étapes, il faut les suivre une par une.
Squeezie : Allez prendre des chaises on va se péter le nez tous ensemble, c'est parti !
Squeezie : Okay, step 5, tu mets le truc, t'attends un peu que ça se solide (?)
Squeezie : Ils ont la pression, c'est génial ! Ils ont trop peur !
Squeezie : Allez vas-y on y va, c'est parti les gars, vite avant que ça refroidisse, on y va, on y va, on y va, on y va !
Squeezie : Hop !
Squeezie : T'en prends un peu
Okay les gars
Micka : J'peux pas mettre ça dans le nez !
Squeezie : * Souffle *
Le mettez pas très profond...
* Rires *
Squeezie : Vous êtes prêts ?
Top !
Jimmy : Faut appuyer, faut appuyer j'crois !
* Rires *
Micka : J'ai plus envie de le retirer
Squeezie : Les mecs, j'ai jamais autant regretté un truc dans la minute qui-
Jimmy : Ouais, donc en fait, c'que j'te disais c'est queeeuuuh
Squeezie : Ouais on parlait des poils
On retire d'un coup, voir si ça fait quelque chose ?
Squeezie : Y'a un poil, j'ai un poil mais par contre j'ai beaucoup de crottes de nez !
Squeezie : Deuxième essai, deuxième essai
Jimmy : C'est très bizarre comme substance
Squeezie : Tiens Mika, mets vite dans ton nez, après ça refroidit de ouf
Mettez direct dans votre nez, direct dans votre nez !
AHHH ! Tu en as mis sur ma moustache !
Mais arrête ! Tu m'en mets partout !
C'est pas une fondue Micka !
Jimmy : Faut appuyer comme ça.
Squeezie : C'est chaud là.
Mec, le miens il ressemble à rien déjà, quoi...
*Rires*
Squeezie : Vous êtes prêts ?
1, 2, 3, go !
Micka : Moi j'ai rien !
Squeezie : J'ai peur de le faire !
Jimmy : Aller !
Regarde, c'est beau.
Squeezie : J'y vais, j'y vais, j'y vais !
J'ai rien, c'est bon !
J'ai juste un crotte de nez !
Jimmy : Un crotte de nez bien dégueulasse !
*Rires*
Micka : C'est dégueulasse !
Squeezie : C'est ignoble !
Attend parce que j'en ai dans la moustache !
Micka : Peu-être qu'on va aussi retiré les poils de moustache ! *rire*
Jimmy : Tu vas devoir la moustache au micro-onde pour que ça fonde..
*Rires*
Squeezie : Les amis c'est l'heure du dernier article.
À quoi ceci peut bien servir ?
Et pourquoi on ramène plein de bouffe, pourquoi on fait des placements de produits pour Danette et Sodebo
*Rire de micka* On sait pas
C'est simple, c'est une combinaison.
On va se mettre dans cette combinaison.
Ça, se sont en réalité les bras de quelqu'un qui est derrière cette personne.
Voici l'explication de : comment s'enfiler dedans.
Très clair, très efficace,
je propose qu'on s'y attaque de ce pas !
Jimmy : En fait c'est juste un sac poubelle !
Squeezie : Grave !
Micka : Faut que j'aille là dessous ?
Squeezie : Ouais
Et c'est toi qui va passer tes bras dans les trucs là !
Micka : Mais je vois rien là ! Squeezie : Ces bras sont en fait ceux de Micka !
Mais c'est normal que tu voies rien Micka c'est le principe de ce p*tain de jeu !
C'est quoi ça ?
Micka : C'est une tarte au citron.
Squeezie : Ah ok, je veux bien manger s'il-te-plaît
Merci mec. Tu me la prends
J'ai un peu de mal ! *Rires*
C'est bon, c'est bon, c'est bon !
Merci mec !
Elle est pas mauvaise !
Arrête !
Non c'est bon, je la repose, j'ai plus faim.
Oh ! Pardon ! *Rires*
Mec, je veux bien des olives !
Nickel !
Je me suis sali le doigt, c'est relou !
*Rires*
Attend mec, tu vas pas me planter le palet ?!
J'ai jamais été aussi peu serein en mangeant une olive, c'est terrible !
Je veux bien de la banane s'il-te-plaît.
Non plus haut, c'est plus haut.
Non mais mec !
Merci !
Mec, j'aimerai vivre comme ça jusqu’à la fin de ma vie, c'est trop bien !
Le mec fait tout pour toi, t'as pas besoin de bouger !
Ok Micka j'aimerai...
Enfin "Micka"... Pardon, je vais me coiffer.
Il n'y a pas Micka ici.
P'tit tuto beauté, en direct live..
Là, on se frotte les mains tranquillement, on n'hésite pas à bien se les frotter, voilà..
Et là on va sur les cheveux dir-(ect)...
AH p*tain !
À chaque fois je fais l'erreur, excusez-moi !
Ok c'est bon, c'est mon visage.
On se coiffe tranquillement, les veuch
donc faites une coupe un peu comme ça, c'est pas mal
N'hésitez pas pendant ce temps là bien sûr à prendre des olives
Y'a pas de soucis
Régulièrement
On est bon, je pense que je peux arrêter de me coiffer.
*Rires*
Et bien voilà les gens c'est la fin de cette vidéo
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous à plu.
Écoutez, morale de l'histoire,
je n'achèterai plus de truc japonais !
*Rire*
En revanche, le truc qui permet de faire de la macroscopie,
je sais toujours pas si c'est le bon mot
sur son téléphone, c'est très très bon.
En vrai, je trouve qu'il y a un délire assez cool de pouvoir, à portée de main,
faire comme si tu avais un gros microscope
et de pouvoir l'enregistrer surtout, parce que c'est collé à la caméra de ton téléphone
Franchement, c'est pas mal !
Je vous dis dans une prochaine vidéo et...
*Sifflet*
Faites moi un petit 500 mètre là !
*Outro*